so you're kind of derailing the combo so  not not even talking about this the  reason I think water women like to be  cheated on is because they catch him  cheating they never leave and I've had  girl after girl after girl after girl  and sometimes they do but whenever I ask  when did you leave it's never when they  catch him cheating it's like when he  stops it's like it's too late now it's  like no no it's like they cheat  they catch him and then six months later  then you leave what yeah  you had left when he was cheating so so  in my head it's like when he's cheating  when she has actual evidence of a  cheating she stays when she has no  evidence of him cheating she leaves so  modern women like to be cheated on  that's my point